quand on voit les maltraitances sur des
animaux aux diverses dans les faits
divers qu'on constate régulièrement
normalement la plupart des gens ne sont
pas insensibles c'est pour ça que je
disais qu'on est tous un peu animalis
d'une manière ou d'une autre si l'animal
isme c'est se soucier des animaux et de
ne pas les tenir pour de simples
équivalent de 40 de carotte qui crient
quand on leur fait quand leurs portes
des coûts je pense donc de si une si les
animaux ont des droits c'est pour les
mêmes raisons que les humains ont des
droits c'est parce qu'ils ont une
sensibilité ils ont eu un intérêt à
vivre leur vie pourrait continuer avant
qu'on décide de l'écourter en plus de
manière violente
tout ça fait que normalement il n'est
pas illégitime je crois de soutenir une
position comme la nôtre c'est tout à
fait conforme aux disons aux valeurs
communes ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
s'écartent des valeurs communes
simplement on tire les conséquences et
jusqu'au bout de ces valeurs communes
si vous n'aimez pas tuer un chien pour
le manger bon ben il a priori devait
réfléchir aussi à la question de savoir
s'il est bien de tuer une vache ou un
cochon voilà c'est aussi simple que ça
mais au-delà de ces questions sur la
légitimité de la consommation de viande
qui se posent encore de jeu le rappel
depuis des millénaires et j'en vois ceux
qui s'intéressent à la littérature sur
le sujet elle est abondante
je voudrais insister sur un point assez
que de toute façon
au-delà de la question se dire
animalistes il y à la question de
l'impact de la consommation de viande
sur la planète et la planète ne va pas
pouvoir supporter que ça nous plaise ou
non
la consommation de viande à une échelle
globale c'est à dire que tant que ce
sont les les pays dits riches enfin et
qui consomment de la viande la viande la
terre le supporter mais très très
difficilement et sans doute très
provisoirement mais je peux vous assurer
que le jour où les pays émergents et la
chine l'inde etc vont se mettre à
consommer de l'a2 à consommer de la
viande comme comme le nul prévoit
puisque en 2050
la consommation de viande est censé
augmenter par deux je crois que tous ces
débats moraux seront périmées et que je
peux vous assurer que les gens
veron la consommation de viande avec un
peu moins de tranquillité qu'on peut le
faire actuellement
[Musique]